he was once music's public enemy number
one when I was younger it wasn't my
dream to become like a singer or a
rapper especially one a career just cuz
I couldn't speak the language I
definitely kind of paved my own way for
myself need motivation watch a top ten
with believe nation what's that believe
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in Seattle and writing
raps during high school to moving to
South Korea to pursue his musical
ambitions to coming home and becoming an
all-star musician in entrepreneur he's
jay Park and he was my take on his top
ten rows of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one seize your opportunities he was once
music's public enemy number one
and former leader of 2 p.m. one of the
biggest boy bands in Asia you know I
don't know how to
he was a fallen angel who was cast into
Korean pop purgatory but genuine talent
always prevailed he shrugged off a
social media scandal to become the
biggest solo star in Korea got taken
down by social media but social media is
what brought him back up again I really
think that made him stronger he takes
every situation and girls from it when I
was younger it wasn't my dream to become
like a singer or a rapper especially one
in Korea just cuz I couldn't speak the
language but you know I had kind of had
this opportunity in front of me and I
you know I took advantage of it
basically you know I I didn't take it
for granted I worked I worked my ass off
you know I was I was a rehearsing every
day I was in the gym every day I was you
know I took it very seriously I didn't
take it for granted I didn't I didn't I
wanted to make sure that I didn't look
back as a person and we didn't look back
as a group and we represented our people
in the right way rule number two find
your gift I was born here but um so my
mom had me auditioned for this company
and because they're holding auditions
oh she was talented early mom saw it
early I mean you know she so it wasn't
that she saw it early so this is what it
is she wanted me to be like a doctor a
lawyer my grades were bad obviously I
wasn't gonna go to you know like I
wasn't gonna get into a university
because I was always break dancing I was
always that goddamn hip-hop yeah started
off as a b-boy and battling and all that
and then um she's just like okay let's
see where you stand go audition for this
thing they're doing this thing and then
I went and did it and they you know
they're like y'all being his boy band so
I wasn't like a boy band for like a year
yeah yeah
at first they definitely you know didn't
like the fact because I could have been
doing like more pop so it just took like
an easier route but then you know this
is what this is me so it's just kind of
like I just had to do me and then just
hopefully they would see and now they're
not complaining you know it's like they
live in there he's coming in live in the
house about him and you know and
obviously it's not I'm not out here
running amuck you know I'm very I'm a
very positive person I do a lot for my
people I do a lot for you know just
everybody that's around me so rule
number three overcome obstacles
you say like yeah you know you stab
yourself in high-poverty but it wasn't
it was not an easy road you know it's
kind of like I had a lot of obstacles
just me not being able to speak in
language my Korean was definitely not up
to standard you know even now it's like
I understand maybe and can read or write
and do like maybe 85 90 percent before
it was at like 20 percent or like me
being from a group like a boy band
background and whatnot everybody was
very very skeptical but you know it's
like if you just keep at it
it took about seven eight years but you
know here I'll do this room before
figure it out on the go what was it like
to suddenly be in South Korea as an 18
year old and in this kind of interesting
situation I mean it was it was you know
very unfamiliar for me very unfamiliar
and yeah I mean I didn't know how to
assess it I didn't know what I was
getting into I didn't even know what
like a boy band in Korea was and then I
was an artist development for about four
years and so I didn't even know what a
trainee was I didn't know what I would
be doing over there and then so kind of
like I figured it out as you know as I
went along it was very hard for me you
know because I was away from my first
time being away from what my family my
friends in going to a place where I
can't really speak the language I didn't
really understand the culture you know
the food didn't match me right all right
I didn't really like the food at that
time because it didn't match my taste or
whatever and so yeah I had a really you
know rough few months a couple years for
sure yeah rule number five turn
negatives into positives as a bamboo
riding high in 2010
years earlier an innocuous email
conversation with a friend from the US
written during his trainee days was to
bring his career to a screeching halt
the email in which Jay wrote of being
homesick while also detailing the
culture shock that was leaving him
unsettled and uncertain of his future in
Korea was somehow mysteriously leaked to
the media the consequences were
devastating
JYP made a snap decision and told Jay to
pack his bags
the lead singer of an outrageously
popular boy band in Korea has fled that
country and landed here in western
Washington although J was the leader of
a band that has racked up gold records
and millions of fans after being sacked
by the band's backers Jay was left with
nothing to show for his years of hard
work and dedication I didn't want to
spend my parents money I've been in
Korea for like three four years didn't
really have anything show so for you
know bunch of hate comments online the
wheels of fortune had stopped spinning
for Jay he was forced to take up a
minimum-wage job changing tires in a
backstreet garage in Seattle just to
make ends meet I really think that made
him stronger it's got this optimistic
character so I think you really learned
a lot from that I guess one night after
12-hour shift at the garage Jay dared to
dream again he picked up a laptop given
to him as a gift by some of his fans in
Korea Jay had an idea beautiful girls
all over the world already saw it up and
I knew on the radio I love the saj will
cover this and put it up on YouTube and
[Music]
it went super violet got 2 million views
in one day that video got change back on
the map back on the radar and there was
opportunities for him to come back
[Music]
that laptop was a lifeline and proved to
be a launch pad to a new solo career
this was the spark which to everyone's
surprise reignited interest in Jays
talent for the first time ever no one's
telling me you do this do that do this
is I'm completely on my own that was
kind of like loved it to really like it
just straight up get back into it soon
the Seattle Exile was over it was time
to return and take on the Korean pop
establishment this time on his own terms
rule number six follow your gut he has
myself I needed someone to kind of a
cool to bounce around ideas and to feed
off each other and just to have fun
making music because it was just me and
in the engineering everybody I was
working with was you know in the States
so I kind of felt very alone in this
music journey and also a lot of people a
lot of labels I feel like their their
business is not official in terms of
being transparent and so I was like
y'all can't if I want to avoid that just
need to start my own label
so I established a oMG 2013 my
management at the time to really really
my parents it was like too big of a risk
but if I believed in it if I see the
vision like I just need to go with my
gut and just go with it you know despite
what anyone says and turned out for the
best so I wanted it's one of the biggest
you know labels out there right now
hip-hop is rule number seven earn
respect how do you feel about people's
reaction to like especially like my
first that was a real reaction at
percent before we started I told you
like yo I didn't think it was gonna be
that dope but it's hard
yeah like are you is that something you
expect or is it something that's still
like that's good that's something I
appreciate yeah you know say I don't I
don't expect easy props I don't expect
just because you know I stashed myself
over there or have a big following that
you just automatically assume that I'm
dope or that you you know it's like I
wanna I want to earn my respect just
like that's me rule number eight be
passionate i J what I want to know is
what advice would you give to someone
record label you know I get I get this
question a lot like people ask me all
the time I think you just have to have a
passion for like you know singing
dancing rapping or or whatever acting or
you know being a comedian or whatever
you want to do like you have to have a
big passion for it so that you you know
you do it a lot you live it breathe it
whatever I mean not to sound corny or
anything but if you do it like that then
you can't help but get good at it and
people you know they see that so I think
I think it would just be like practice a
lot but have fun with it and make sure
it's your passion rule number nine pave
your own way I was the leader of the
group 2:00 p.m. the whole reason I went
over to Korea was because I got casted
to be in the group it was an artist
development I guess you could say it was
a training or whatever for about four
years
wasn't the group for about a year and
then you know just some drama happened
and then and when I departed from the
group started doing my solo thing that's
when I had more control over music in my
career and that's when I really started
you know just going in on the music it's
definitely like a machine you know I was
you know they're very well polished the
choreographies super on point they got
everything down to like a formula to a
tee so that's why it's it can't fail you
know I'm saying I mean what I do is a
little bit different a little bit more
organic a little bit more natural I
guess my music really represents me as a
person as an artist I definitely kind of
paved my own way for myself and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is perform amazingly
born in this country but I'm feeling
like an immigrant so we gotta look out
for one another
you're my brother I don't care about
your basic color get they beating up on
you huh feeling some type of way so I'll
make sure that we're all good to live
another day I got compassion in my heart
with the mind of a genius the hustle of
a street do with the pages of Jesus when
I say it I mean everything to me green
it sorted anybody let them listen
somebody's younger need to put the pot
aside cuz sometimes the ego is deadly
cyanide ain't nobody got a guy who ain't
got a rod y'all both human beings just
ain't seen eye-to-eye
don't fall trivia business on the caucus
system wanna break it down and get rid
of your wit and grit I wanna see you
shackled up and living in the pisses I
mean while they make a stupid money any
Stanley these are my observations I
never go on vacation this woman be my
temptation I'm cooking on either apron
assalamualaikum - the heavens and earth
say your prayer for my enemies but never
at church but it's worse than a lot of
lonely millionaires I've seen a smile on
orphan all the [ __ ] I can't fix the
world so I leave it in God's hands
there's no little part of me will always
care swing now I've got a really special
bonus clip from Jay on how to have a
good work ethic that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life run your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave the answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
negative in your life can you turn into
a positive number two what is your gift
and number three what does paving your
own way look like for you
what do you have to say to all like the
fans out there because I just talked to
some of the fans they were just playing
crazy I mean one girl like literally
just passed out and I'm just like Hello
like where are you
but like what what do you like the kind
of advice do you have them for fans yeah
I think who look up to you who want to
do this oh I want to do this I mean it's
first of all I think you have to have
the right intentions if you're just
your fame I don't think you'll get
anywhere with this
enjoy the app dashboard and you you have
to system or thing I think is most
important also you feel if you're lazy
you know this is not the job for you
Chris
is crazy hard and you're crazy busy you
gotta put in a lot of work and it just
be very passionate about it and positive
you can enjoy succeed someday but when
you would would soon once wolves long
you down the most important work ever if
you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would become like a little
beacon
[Music]
if you like this video check out them
making it as a musician video that I
made I think you can enjoy the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I want to tell you the most important
piece of information that applies not
only to your musical career but your
entire life